[拍手]
今日はどうぞわー
融合高3年の
吉村太郎と申しますどうぞよろしくお願い致します
ni
後半ば常界からという話であろうすいません
一回っていうのは軟体動物
分類されるのでして
軟体動物の話だけ
お堅い話でございませんので皆さん最後まで気軽にお
やばというふうに思います
私は10校に入学してからいろんなことを
作業の紹介となりましたように
空手とか
本当はここに a
[音楽]
海の研究編という風に書いておりますけれどもこれには別にあのカラーて編とまずは
勉強連符も勉強たい触れたんですけど
行く使う
取り組んでいることがあってそのうちの一つを今日はご紹介させていただければという
ふうに思います
これはあの全部統一人物でして
打ってそれは私なんですけれども
からではノー国際強化選手今しておりますか
本当は母てで高校に入学させてもらいました
いい
ですか今日は海外を話している
他にもあの星当会の活動だったりとか茶道の
出前をしたりそれから学会で発表したいと言う
非常に充実した10校生活を送らせて頂いた
ことはあの慶応高校に入学した理由というのがあ
からでのが非常に強いということが一つありまして
それから勉強ができる
イメージが非常にできる格好であるんです
勉強ができる格好っていうのは他にもあります
あるいはから税の税額50のほかにもあると思うんですけれども
勉強とから税
それから研究その全てがへ
全力で取り組める環境というのは慶應義塾高校以外にないというふうに思います
これは実行役員だから言わされているわけではなくてですね
ame
本当にああああ
がぜひある
真の10校の8を4回音楽室の前にはですね
会議研究室というのがありまして
絵画など
がこういうふうに300台以上広域表示並んでいるわけなんですけれども
こういうヘアでいつも研究させていただいております
非常に恵まれた環境なんですが
こういった研究をするきっかけとなった話を
まずはは
たいと思います
きっかけはということで
北陸の福井の出身でして中学まで福井でお伝え
を剃らずにもあります今越前ガニが大変おいしい季節でね
ぜひあのこの時期に福井に来ていらっしゃるかなというふうに思い
それから
福井の海岸というのはあの
沿岸中の関係も相まって貝殻が大変あの
チェーンたくさん打ち上がる海岸です
そこで貝拾いをしていたというのがね
はじめのきっかけでもあると思います
貝拾いをしていましたら1000種類以上の外からが集まりましてん
先週市はけっこうすごい
ません
ポケモンが800ちょっとなんです
選手率がばそれなりにすごい
たでしてな
こういうふうにあの
第一がありません
1位
こんな感じですねあります
これはの本当に微小なの1ミリにも満たないような貝殻を拾い集める
他の女が視力が両目とも2.0以上あるんですけれどもそれでも
あのー
これくらい
を砂浜と思う
近くにみないとその砂の爪とかい
歯磨きられないくらいそういう風だ
変な作家1000種類ぐらい集めるとそういうか
次回になってき
1000種類ぐらい集めたらそれは新種も一つぐらい見つかるだろうというところなん
ですけれども
あのそのあたりをちょっと
グラムとしてお話しさせていただきたいと思います
この新種というのが
これから戸建てのグループ中な皆さんもよく知る来たぜのグループなんですけど
2てのグループではもう信じがないというふうに言われてきました
実際にその集めたあの
エゾ巾着がいて向かいなんですけれどもええぞキンチャクダイの仲間も一族で一緒でし
た
それを3時にしたという研究がこれからのは
けれども
それから
高校生が
二歳児の母プロンプを投稿するということも
なかなかないことです
これも
スライドにはの
方向でしかなし得ないからわざというお掛けしましたけれども
本当に
少し無理なところを
[音楽]
先行力技れ
を押したみたいなそんなところもあります
大変お待たせを致しましたん
これが幅の親子の
貝化石の
発表せしたい
いますね
内容じゃ初公開でございます
14前からカウンターですぎてるならじゃないんだから
さあ皆さんご一緒にありがとうございます
7のっ
ローン
いい
スレ car
あの二枚貝額乙なお中に埋まって一つの方向が見え低下な形なんですけれどもこれは座
のレプリカでして本物は今
博物館の方に所蔵されているんですけれども
そのレプリカが違う形の警報この地学教室に置いてございます
もしご興味のある方は違うかバレー
この度この新種の会の研究が
論文が投稿を受理されまして
ここに
自分の記事では米んといけん給与年というふうに階でございますけれども
論文があの
投稿してから受理されるまでは
すごく長い時間がかかりまして
その間カード
のな方にお世話になりました
慶応高を始めとして慶應義塾大学の理工学部や法学空など
今後あの理系の専門家だけではなくて
軸内のたくさんの方々にお世話になった
例えば
論文の中にはあの
引用文献の中に英語で書かれたものはもちろんありますけど
フランス語とかおっしゃお金が書かれたものをたくさんありまして
これを
1人読むというのは大変ですよね
翻訳しながら4棟
ということで大学の線
生や高校の
+もの先生にお世話になりながら
だと言う
いうふうにある
いつもあの取材というかあの
テレビとか新聞の取材なんかでは惹かれた時に何時もご対するんですけれども
いつも使われないというセリフがありまして
今日はこの場でこそ伝えしたいというふうに思っている
をいう風な研究というのは
オールけいおんの力があったんじゃないかと思います
おりキロというのはあの
大会でよく使われる言葉ですけれどもポインターの文科系の
活動にこそたくさんの専門
複数の分野の専門家
ご協力があってこそ成立したものです
むじょんクラスメイトとか軸ないの
近くにんが周りの方々のご協力
非常に大きいですけれども
これらの
分野をまたまたいい
学際的な支援をいただいたというのが
焼いてここまでやってこられました
の方に
場をお借りして改めて御礼を申し上げたいと思いますありがとうございました
ます